And we are live. Uh thank you for being
here and an especially warm welcome if
this is your first time with us,
Adventist or otherwise. So we are back
with another open discussion. Really
looking forward to it.
Question of the night,
thesis for the night. Is the 7th
Adventist doctrine of the investigative
judgment biblical?
That is the question in focus tonight.
Is the seventh adventist doctrine of the
investigative judgment biblical?
But before we bring in our guests, I
want to remind you all that Answering
Adventism is a viewerup supported
effort. If you like what we are doing
here, please consider partnering with us
by visiting answering
adventism.com/donate
or you can use the link in the
description box down below. It is
through the generosity and support of
our partners that we are able to fulfill
our mission to equip as many Christians
as possible to reach as many Seventh Day
Adventists as possible with the true
Christ and his gospel. It has been a
fantastic 2024 for this platform and a
large part of that success is due to our
partners. So, thank you all so much for
your continued support and this is
absolutely a team effort. With that
said, gentlemen, thank you both for
being here. Joel, I will start with you
for those that do not know. Let people
know who you are and then Sam, I'll let
you do the same.
All right. Uh uh Miles, do you hear me?
Yes.
Okay, great. So, I'm Joel Da. I'm from
the Netherlands. I am 32 years old and I
have been grown up within Adventism and
I think the last 12 years I really
emerged myself into the study of uh
theology but also Adventist doctrines
because I wanted to really know what I
am up to what I need to believe
especially in this world where we have a
secular worldview predominantly
uh reigning. So um by God's grace I uh I
studied myself through the Bible and
also to the Adventist doctrines in
especially with regards to salvation and
um here I am to um yes to share what I
think is the biblical truth and why I do
think that Adventism is indeed uh in
many ways um yes according what the
Bible says. So yeah.
Great. Well thank you for being here
Sam. whatever you would like to share as
well for people who may not know or be
familiar with who you are.
Well, I'm probably one of their favorite
heretics, right?
Possibly.
Um, yeah, I'm equally disliked by all
various groups, whether Jehovah's
Witnesses or Mormons or Adventists or
Protestants. Even Catholics don't like
me. But yeah, by the grace of the Lord
Jesus Christ, you know my story, Miles.
I've been on a journey. My faith to
Christ started in the 90s and I've
studied and I was a staunch Calvinist
for a while. But as I study more and I
seek the spirit more, one of my prayers
is the spirit perfects my theology and
perfects my obedience and holiness. So
destroy all false teaching error in me
and give me the grace to be humble and
teachable to see where I'm mistaken and
accept correction and accept the
fullness of the truth even if it makes
me unpopular. So as people know, I'm in
the Catholic Church which I know a lot
of people don't like but that's where my
journey has brought me. So we trust the
Lord Jesus to bring us into the fullness
and have mercy on us. So I do believe
the Lord meets you where you're at and
he sees what you know and he takes that
in consideration and he's a God of
infinite mercy. If you know the truth
and resist it, it's one thing but if you
are not fully aware of what the fullness
of the truth is, I believe the Lord
Jesus is a merciful God and he has
compassion. So I pray that for all of
us.
Amen. So a quick rundown for the
audience to let everyone know the agenda
for the night.
I will be neutally moderating like I
usually do in these discussions. I will
kick things off tonight by reading the
entirety of the Seventh Day Adventist
fundamental belief number 24 on the
sanctuary and the investigative
judgment. This will be followed by an
hour and a half of back and forth
discussion between both Sam and Joel
over the thesis question. I will only
step in if things get out of hand or off
track, which I do not anticipate. After
the half, hour and a half, each
individual will then have a fivem minute
closing to wrap up their thoughts
uninterrupted.
Gentlemen, final point. When you hear
this,
that will indicate that there is one
minute left. So,
in the open dialogue as well as your
closing statements.
All right.
If you hear it a second time, that means
time is up. Sometimes when you're
talking and that sound goes off, it's
easy for you to not hear it. So, if I
abruptly cut you off, I'm not trying to
do so. I'm just going to let you know,
hey, that the time is up. But feel free
to finish your thought if you're in the
middle of one and I do that. Any
questions?
Yeah, I kind of feel bad. I'm old enough
to be his dad. How old are you, Miles?
Um, old enough
because I'm wondering if I'm old enough
to use that because he said he's 32. I'm
52. That sucks. I'm getting old, man.
You You could be You You could be. We'll
We'll say that. I'll leave it there.
You guys suck, man. But anyway, you got
Merc
is just a number,
but it's bold number.
Yeah.
Well, if it makes you feel any better,
Sam, I'm starting to wear hats more and
more. That's kind of indicative of my
age. Um, so I need to maybe just let it
go. But with that said, let's read the
entirety of the fundamental belief so
the audience uh understands what it is
that we are discussing tonight.
It reads, quote, "There is a sanctuary
in heaven, the true tabernacle that the
Lord set up and not humans. In it,
Christ ministers on our behalf, making
available to believers the benefits of
his atoning sacrifice offered once for
all on the cross." At his ascension, he
was inaugurated as our great high priest
and began his intercessory ministry
which was typified by the work of the
high priest in the holy place of the
earthly sanctuary. In 1844 at the end of
the prophetic period of 2300 days, he
entered the second and last phase of his
atoning ministry which was typified by
the work of the high priest in the most
holy place of the earthly sanctuary. It
is a work of investigative judgment
which is part of the ultimate
disposition of all sin typified by the
cleansing of the ancient Hebrew
sanctuary on the day of atonement. In
that typical service, the sanctuary was
cleansed with the blood of animal
sacrifices. But the heavenly things are
purified with the perfect sacrifice of
the blood of Jesus.
The investigative judgment reveals to
heavenly intelligences who among the
dead are asleep in Christ and therefore
in him are deemed worthy to have part in
the first resurrection. It also makes
manifest who among the living are
abiding in Christ, keeping the
commandments of God and the faith of
Jesus and in him therefore are ready for
translation into his everlasting
kingdom.
This judgment vindicates the justice of
God in saving those who believe in
Jesus. It declares that those who have
remained loyal to God shall receive the
kingdom. The completion of this ministry
of Christ will mark the close of human
probation before the second advent.
Close quote. And then you see the proof
text that they provide for their
position.
So to kick off the discussion, Joel, we
will let you break the ice on the hour
and a half. You can present your first
biblical argument to Sam that you
believe proves the investigative
judgment is a biblical doctrine. The
time will begin when you begin speaking,
sir.
All right. Uh thank you very much, Amal.
Um so when it comes to the this
doctrine, I would like to start with um
the tradition wherein we stand as
Adventists. We stand in the tradition of
Jacob's Arminius and he maintained the
idea of Prinian grace. Profenian grace
involves the idea that God gave every
human creature free will. So if there is
free will that is the basis of the idea
of having a judgment. You cannot have a
judgment uh in the culinic sense often
where someone's life is determined if
you already know to say that everything
was determined beforehand. So that's
very important. We stand in that
tradition. Now when it comes to
justification by faith, according to the
Bible, we receive eternal life, the hope
of eternal life already at our initial
justification. So give let me give an
example. Romans 5:21, John 5:4,
Titus 3, they maintain the idea when
we're justified, we receive eternal
life. However, when it comes to the
reception of eternal life, the Bible
also makes clear there are two things
needed. Not only the ticket, which is
justification, but we also need the
right fitness. Looking at Luke chapter
9, Jesus himself said, "The one who put
his hand on the plow." Do you hear me?
Hello. Hello.
Did you Miles, did you mute my mic?
You're speaking too fast and slow down a
bit. You said you need two things
because I know you're not here to
preach. You want to engage. So, we're
going to try to engage.
So, you need two things. What was the
two things you need? Because John 5:24
without looking at the context or Titus
3.
Yeah. Which which which first did you
mention?
Which one did you mention? Two things
because we're talking about the
investigative judgment. So, we want to
Yes. Two things. We need the
justification that is the put
righteousness but we also need fitness
in terms of holiness. Holiness of heart
fitness only.
How does that tie in? I want you to show
me the investigative judgment and how it
convened in 1844 because this discussion
you're having
there. I don't think anyone who is not
Calvinist would have an issue with what
you're talking about. What the debate
here if you see the title of the debate
is the investigative judgment which you
say took place in 1844 where Jesus
enters into a second phase. So that's
the title. I'd like you to focus on
that. What's the scriptural support for
that?
Okay. So uh what I wanted to just give
me those five minutes and then I I I'm
making my case. So I just um we need
fitness and that fitness is
indicated by our work. So in looking at
Romans chapter 2 verse 5 up to verse 7
we see that Paul says there eternal life
is given to those who have the right
mind orientation heart but then he says
that is accordance to perseverance and
good works. And then in verse five,
still looking at the context, Paul says
there that God will judge everyone
according to his works. He will grant
eternal life according to the works. So
we see here that works are indication of
what lives in the heart and the heart is
the final precondition for eternal life.
Now, now comes it. If works are the
indication that already somehow implies
that there is an investigation going. We
can look at some biblical verses later
on. But the concept that works are not
the firmmost the foremost thing but they
are indication of what lives in the
heart and that we are judged according
to our works already shows oh something
is going on of a trial. Now when it
comes to an investigative judgment, I um
I already maintained it a couple of
times in other uh interviews. We have to
look at a judgment order in the Bible.
So you will always see there is a
judgment before the second coming
oh so you have so let me just let me
just give the two faces and I will give
you the Bible verses. So you will see
that God the father is the judge before
the second coming where it will be
determined he will determine who will be
saved and then Jesus will execute it.
Let me give you the verses Psalm 110
Psalm and by the way all these verses
are post Calvary. So this judgment
speaking to us is not helping your case.
Okay.
And Psalm 110 in light of the New
Testament is talking about Christ coming
to destroy his enemies on earth.
Revelation 6:15-17.
That's why I'm saying instead of
throwing thousands of verses, get to the
verse so we can go through and exedute
them.
Uh Sam Sam, give me those five minutes.
Give me those five minutes. So the order
five minutes, but go ahead.
Okay. Have a conversation, but I'll let
you go.
I I had the introduction in five
minutes. That was the icebreaker. So So
listen. So it all the verses I'm going
to mention speak about the judgment done
by the father post Calvary and executed
by Jesus. So Psalm 110 verse one speaks
about uh Yahweh who says to Adonai sit
at my right hand till I give my enemies
to people can verse one
that's verse one and then in verse five
and six it speaks about Adonai Jesus
again who will execute that is what you
see in Matthew chapter 25 you see the
son of man sitting on the right hand of
God at the second coming and then he
bids those welcome who are blessed by
the father and in the Greek it shows
it's a Greek participle in the perfect
tense it shows that the decision making
was already done before the second
coming again 2 Thessalonians chapter 1
Paul speaks here about the Christian
group which already are saved but still
speaks in verse five verse four and five
that they have faith and and endurance
that will be used in the judgment of God
the father verse five and then later on
in verse 7 6-9 he speaks about Christ
who will execute it the same in John
chapter 5 Christ said all judgment is
given to the son of man but again he
will execute it verse 26 verse 30 says
as I hear I will judge revelation
chapter 14 God the father is the
judgment of God the father is the first
angel message when Jesus comes back with
a sickle on the clouds he has a sickle
in his hand to execute the judgment 2
Corinthians Chapter 5, you will see it
again in chap verse 9, it speaks about
whether we are present or absent that we
might be accepted. And then verse 10,
because we all have to appear before the
judgment seat of Christ. So hey Joel,
let's not let's let's not gish gallop
because we're getting a lot of of verses
thrown out here, but we're not actually
able to look at and there's a lot of
things that there's a lot of things
you're saying that that Christians just
generally speaking are going to agree
with. We want to talk about the
specifics of whether it's that this
investigation began in 1844 that Jesus
was inaugurated to be a priest at his
ascension something along those lines
that's very specific and we'll focus on
point by point.
Yeah.
Okay. So why you know why I mention this
first because if you cannot accept this
concept which is often the case because
many Christians seem to uh uh confine
the judgment only at the second coming
you never observe an investigative
judgment but if you see the order
yeah so let's look at some of those
verses that you've mentioned let's look
at some of those I'm going to he
butchered every one of them so I'm going
to butcher his butchering but I just got
to make sure I maybe I didn't remember I
have my screen up I didn't Remember,
it's okay. He can speak his five
minutes, but I don't recall he was going
to have five minutes to preach and Gish
Galla, but that's okay because I'm going
to school his distortion every passage
that he misqued, but I just want to make
sure he's not here to preach, right? I
got it. We can engage.
Let's engage. Let's engage.
Now, let me let me deal with young man.
I know you're young. Take it easy. It's
okay. Let me deal with your butchering
of Psalm 110. I try to correct your
statement. If you look at the Hebrew, it
says Naom
Adoni, he's speaking to Adoni. I just
wanted to correct that. That's not a
major point, but it doesn't
What did I say? What did I say?
You said Adonai.
Oh, sorry. Okay. Okay. Yeah. Is it
pronunciation?
No, it's not pronunciation. It's two
different words in the vowel marking.
So, if you let me
What I mean is that Yahweh is speaking
to
Adonai. First one,
brother. If he's going to cut me off,
you know, the guy scared. So I'm trying
to be respectful. It's on your channel.
I can't even make a point for him
manifesting.
Okay. No, it's not the same word. Uh Don
is different. I just all I want to
correct. And
contrary to what you say, Psalm 110
shows that it's being fulfilled from the
time that Christ ascended to sit at
God's right hand. God is already slowly
destroying his enemies. Slowly but
surely. So this is why I say when you do
gish gallop and throw a thousand verses,
you're only embarrassing yourself
because you can't execute any one of
them. So, I'm going to walk through you.
Let me just do this slowly.
Mhm.
I show you what it says. Because
contrary to your assertion,
the father, the son together now are
slowly destroying Christ's enemies until
he returns. But let me just show that.
Let me just give you one that uses the
word Yahweh. And we still didn't get to
the investigator of John 19:44. That was
what I came to debate. But that's fine.
But let's go here. Yahweh says to my
Lord, "Sit at my right hand until I put
your enemies a foottool for your feet."
Okay. Now, let's see how the New
Testament interprets this. Yahweh says
to my Lord, "Sit on my right hand until
I put your enemies as a foottool for
your feet." I'm going to now let the New
Testament interpret this. 1 Corinthians
15. And by the way, just to let you
know, let's go here. Let me start
earlier. Then you want to try to chime
in and address these passages. But let's
let the New Testament instead of gish
galloping. 1 Corinthians 15:20 to28. But
now Christ has been raised from the
dead, the first fruits of those who have
fallen asleep. For since by a man came
death, by a man also came the
resurrection dead. For as in Adam all
die, so also in Christ all will be made
alive. But each in his own order, Christ
the first fruits. After that those who
are Christ that is coming. Then comes
the end when he hands over the kingdom
of God, the to the God and father. when
he's abolished all rule and all
authority and power. For he must reign
until he has put all his enemies under
his feet. The last enemy to be abolished
is death. For he has put all things in
subjection under his feet. But when he
says all things are put in subjection,
it is evident that he is accepted who
put all things in subjection to him.
When all things are subjected to him,
then the son himself will also be
subjected to the one who subjected all
things to him so that God may be all in
all. So if we follow the flow here and
Hebrews 10:123 confirms Christ when he
ascended into heaven and sat enthroned
at right hand that begins the
subjugation and destruction of Christ's
enemies until the last enemy is
destroyed when he returns. Hebrews
10:12-13.
But he having offered one sacrifice for
sins for all time sat at the right hand
of God waiting from that time since what
time? When he sat at God's right hand
which took place after his ascension
waiting from that time until his enemies
are put as a foottool for his feet. So I
don't know what you are trying to prove
by saying that God is now judging and
then Christ will judge because if you're
saying that it is God currently judging
not the son you have the son
contradicting you because in John
5:22-23
for not even the father judges anyone
but he's given all judgment to the son
and he doesn't say at the second coming
all judging whether present past or
future is the sons. So what exactly has
this to do with the investigative
judgment? Connect it for me.
Okay. So uh first of all going back to
Hebrews chapter 10, it speaks about
Jesus sitting at the right hand of God
and it says he waits till his enemies
are put subject. So what I wanted to
make clear with this point is it is God,
it's Yahweh who is in charge of putting
enemies under Jesus' feet. So that was
the point I wanted to make.
What does it have to do of judgment or
walks away?
Because it is the order is Jesus sitting
at the right hand of God. He waits till
his enemies are put forth. And then
according to verse 5 going back to Psalm
110. It is again Jesus who will execute
the wrath in the day and he will execute
the judgment in the day of his wrath.
You're distorting these verses. Let me
repeat what I said to
Yeah. Well, let me show you. Take it
easy. If I thought you're right, I'd be
an Adventist. Take it easy. John 5:22
says, "You're misreading it because it
says,"For not even the father judges
anyone." Anyone, but he's given all
judgment to the son and he's not
qualifying it. You can keep reasoning
your repeat what I just said because
you're not listening.
I I heard it. Let me repeat.
No, no, repeat it. No, I want to see.
Repeat.
Yeah. Repeat what I said.
So Jesus said, "The father judges no
one, but he has all given all judgment
to the son." But we have to read it in
context. The context context is
can I can I can explain you want me to
right explain
actually waiting for investigative
judgment 184.
This is all connected to it. This all
connected to it.
Bring me to it. Give me the evidence.
Okay. So let me also so in verse 26 and
27 speaks about that God who uh in verse
27 it uses the Greek words po poin that
means to execute judgment. And then
verse 28, last wait
execute judgment. Verse 28 and 29 speaks
about the rest of the
let me bring up the Greek. Stop
shouting.
Let's go to the Greek.
What?
Verse 27. Verse 27.
Miles, if this guy's going to yell, he
can't control himself.
Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. Let's go verse 27.
What verse? So I want you to break down
27. 27.
Okay. But I want to bring up the entire
one because again
when does
but I can't even talk with this guy
cutting me off.
No, you uh my friend, you say things and
I would like to respond.
No, you haven't anything. I'm still
waiting. You're wasting time here.
Okay.
I want to now after this I want you to
go to the investigative judgment. Stop
the tap dance. Okay. Now
we're going to start in verse 27. He
says
go contact
man. My goodness, dude. Take it easy.
Okay.
Read for me the Greek. Don't read the
English.
I read the Greek for you. It says there.
Uh, it says there
25. Start at 25.
27.
25.
Okay. 25. Amen.
Loudly.
My brother, can I just finish because
Okay,
go ahead.
Now move on. Wait, before you move on,
parse what it means. Kun,
which first are you referring to?
25 where it says
noon.
Yes.
What does that mean?
And now is
what's what is?
And now is now is
that the dad will hear his voice.
Speak speak in the mic so I can hear you
because I can't hear you too.
And now is when the dead will hear his
voice.
The voice of the son of God.
Do you understand the significance of
that?
It means that already now Christ has the
power to res people from the dead.
Glad you said that. So stop trying to
show me that because you have either
future tense somehow it implies this is
a future action when here the Lord says
what he's going to do he's already began
doing at his first coming. But that was
my point. I did not even mention the but
I I went to the context in verse 28 and
29 where it speaks about the
resurrection of the dead and yes but in
that context Paul speaks about uh oh
sorry not Paul about he he speaks about
two words poin those two words
slowly because your mic is and your
accent is slowly.
So in the within this context of the
resurrection of the dead, he uses those
two words poison and that means to
execute the judgment. Can
to execute the judgment
and then
here Sam let's let's let him let's let
him finish and then you can uh then you
can chime in and then you can chime in
and explain.
No. Yeah. Because he's saying that the
judgment is in reference to the future.
No. if he had understood my point. It
already began now and it culminates in
the judgment. That's why I asked him
about the kayoon and that's confirmed in
John 12 39 to 41. But go ahead. I'm
sorry. John 9 39-41. No, you're
mistaken. It's not simply future. It's
begun now and will culminate at the
resurrection. This is the point I was
making with Hebrews 10:12-13. But you
ignored my argument. But what is that
the judgment going on right now?
Read John 9:39-41 for me. It'll tell
you.
John 9
39-41. Yeah.
It already began
and it will culminate at the second
coming.
John 9. And then what was the first?
39 of 41.
Okay. 39.
And hopefully we get to the
investigative judgment. Well, after this
we we'll look at this point, but then
this will be a perfect thing. I'm going
to kind of lead us here. We'll go to
Revelation 14. Is that Is that cool,
Joel? And we'll talk about the judgment
hour arriving since you're talking about
um well, the investigative judgment as
well as right now the topic of judgment.
Is that fine to go to Revelation 14
after this?
Uh I would I would prefer not the Bible
first, but that is okay with me. Uh I
see that you want to I think you mean
that Jesus
bring up my screen. His mic is very bad.
I can't hear. Bring up my screen here.
Let me uh let me enlarge it. So if
everyone is listening, my point was that
so people understand what my point is.
Christ has already begun what will be
fully culminated at his return. This is
the point and for judgment came into
this world.
What kind of judgment? There are many
types of judgment.
That is relevant because otherwise you
do executing.
That's not true because No, no, no. Take
for example 1 Corinthians 11:31 and 32.
That judgment has to do with Christ
correcting us eternal life.
What was my argument?
You say that judgment here doesn't is
not relevant. What kind of judgment?
That was my argument. What was my
initial argument? I want to see if you
even know what my argument is.
You know what?
You while I try to explain Okay, Sam.
No. What was my argument? Repeat my
argument.
Sam Sam, let's go back. Sam, Sam,
can you please just repeat my arguments
so I know that you know what you're
refuting?
Just repeat it.
That that this judgment already happened
at the Christ event and that it it and
that it will culminate in the
it it culminates it culminates
it culminates at the second coming. But
you already said it happen judgment
started from the beginning. If you had
listened, I said that all the judging is
done by the son, even subjugating his
enemies under his feet. Because if you
had heard me, I said when Christ's sense
to sit at God's right hand, that is when
father and son together are subjugating
all things under Christ's feet and will
culminate in his return. Your argument
was it's the father doing it, then the
son will come and judge. And I said,
you're wrong. That's not what the text
says.
The text says that God will put the
enemies under his foottool, not they
both. It is God.
No. Well, let's read 1 Corinthians 15.
No, you're wrong again here. I mean,
you're not paying attention.
Oh boy. I'm still waiting for 18:44. But
I I wanted to I I wanted to finish John
chapter 5 because you have not read
verse 30.
No, actually I did. I
No, because Jesus said as I'm here, I
feel it to you because I there's I can't
make get heads wave. So, what do you
want to do, Miles? Joel, finish finish
your point in in John five and then
we're going to get to some more
specifics in terms of the fundamental
belief.
Yes. So if we go to John chapter 5
starting with verse 22 to verse uh 30
you will see indeed Christ will is given
the authority to judge but it's in the
context from verse 26
in the terms of the second coming the
the resurrection of the dead and then it
speaks about the execution of the
judgment and by the way the parallel
text with this is Jude chapter one
because only those two words pointer
Can can have you listen to Miles,
please?
Yeah, because
Jude and Jude chapter Can I Can I
Sam? Let's Let's let him Let's let him
finish and then you can respond to all
of it.
Brothers,
brother Miles, if you let this guy Gish
Gallop, that's a cowardly tactic
to
notice. See, and he's talking
about my Hello.
Okay. Fellas.
Okay, gentlemen. Gentlemen,
gentlemen, let's take a breather. We can
have a good discussion here. We can have
a good discussion here. Let's just chill
out. Joel, finish your points from John
five. Sam, just let him finish. Stay in
John 5. If you want to mention stuff in
passing, Joel, you can mention stuff in
passing, but make your point in John 5.
Sam is then going to be given the floor
to respond to that uninterrupted and
then we're going to move on to more
specifics because we're not really
getting into the aspects of the
fundamental belief right now. So finish
your point in John 5 and then Sam's
going to respond to that.
Okay. So in John chapter 5 you find in
verse 24 ice
that phrase you find again in Jude
chapter 1 ice. So they will not come
into judgment.
And again you find poor those the
combination of those two words you find
again both in Jude and in John as it is
in John speaking about the resurrection
and the second coming. Again in Jude
poin you will find in Jude 1 verse4 and
15 speaking about the second coming
again. So we find here two linguistic
things speaking about the second coming.
Yeah.
Okay. Now, let me destroy his butchering
of Jude as he's smirking because now
Jude is going to prove my case. And
Miles, brother, I love you, brother. I
know you're trying to be fair. When you
let him gish gallop, you're letting him
get away with murder. So, I'm going to
have to slaughter him spiritually
because remember he said Jude, right?
But Jude buries you because it says
Jude, Jesus has been judging from the
beginning. Now, I want you to smirk,
Joel. Smirk with me here. Don't Don't
take it easy. Now, I'm going to smirk
back at you guys. Let's read context
which he doesn't like to do. He likes to
pull it out of context. Verse 5. Now I
want to remind you though you know all
things that Jesus having once saved the
people out of the land of Egypt
subsequently destroys those who did not
believe. Oh that sure sounds like it's
Jesus who's been doing the judging from
the beginning. And angels who do not
keep their own domain but abandon their
proper abode. This is why people think
they know Greek are dangerous. He has
kept an eternal bonds under darkness for
the judgment of the great day. Just as
Sodom and Gomorrah and the cities around
them having indulged in the same as
these and gross sexual morality and
having gone after strange flesh are
exhibited as an example and undergoing
the punishment eternal fire. Now I want
everyone I'm going to read it because he
thought he can go to Jude and say see
it's future. What was my point which he
still did not address. Jesus has been
doing the judging from the beginning.
And here you have Jesus. And if if you
want to go with the term Lord in the
context of Jesus, he's the one who's
been destroying and judging God's
enemies from the beginning until the
end. And let's continue. Yet in the same
way, these men also by dreaming defile
the flesh and reject authority and
blasphemous glory blasphe glorious ones.
But Michael the archangel when he
disputing with the devil was arguing
about the body of Moses did not dare
pronounce against them a blasphemous
judgment but said the Lord rebuke you.
So much for Jesus being Michael. But
these men blasphe the things which they
do not understand and the things which
they know by instinct like unreasoning
animals. By these things they are
destroyed. Woe to them for they have
gone the way of Cain and for pay they
have poured themselves into the air of
Balam and perish in the rebellion of
Kora. These are the men who are hidden
reefs in your love feast. When they
feast with you without fear, caring for
themselves, clouds without water,
carried along by winds, autumn's trees
without fruit, doubly dead, uprooted,
wild waves of the sea, casting up their
own fo shame like foam, wandering stars
for whom the black darkness has been
reserved forever. But Enoch in the seven
generations from Adam also prophesied
about these men, saying, "Behold, the
Lord came with many thousands of
hisians." Now guys, what's ironic, this
again buries his argument because this
is a citation of the book of Watchers,
chapter 1:9. I'm going to challenge
every one of you guys, go read the
context. It's talking about a past
judgment that the Lord Jesus inflicted
with his glory ones as a sign. He'll
continue to do so when he returns, which
has been my point. He's been executing
judgment from the beginning. This just
buried your argument if you're paying
attention. But you're not paying
attention, Joel. But Enoch in the seven
generation from Adam also prophesied
about these men, saying, "Behold, the
Lord came with many thousands of his
holy ones to execute judgment upon all
to convict all the ungodly of all their
ungodly deeds which they have done in an
ungodly way, and of all the harsh things
which ungodly sinners have spoken
against them. These are grumblers
finding fault, following up their own
lust, and their mouth speaks arrogantly,
flattering people for the sake of their
own benefit." So the very passage you
cited buried you because Enoch 1:9 isn't
talking about second coming. It's
talking about the Lord coming with his
thousands once to destroy the watchers
and that hybrid as a guarantee. The same
Lord who did in the past will continue
to destroy the wicked until the end. And
who is that Lord? Now I want to remind
you though you know all things that
Jesus having once saved the people out
of the land subsequently destroyed those
who not believe. So this made my point
if you understood my point. When God
judges, the father judges. He does it
through the son. He's been doing it from
the beginning. He did it on earth. Which
is why I said why the relevance of this
word. Here you go, friend. Since you
wanted to go there and I'm still waiting
for 1844 because none of this makes your
case. This is why I asked you right here
when it says, "Truly I say to you, an
hour is coming and it now is." This
means it is already begun
and it will culminate in his return. So
the judging and the raising of the dead
isn't something the son does in the
future. He's doing it now to guarantee
he will then continue do it till the
end. That's why in John 9:39 says and
Jesus said for judgment I came into this
world. So I'm still waiting Joel for the
argument of the investigative judgment.
Can you get to 1844 and stop the tempt
please? That's what I'm here for. 1844.
You know, honestly, I'm not really for
me it's not the most important thing.
1844, that's the time, right? For me,
it's the concept, the most important
thing. That was what why I started with
it. Uh that is like Perifer for me. Uh
the uh the date.
No, it's got to be major for you.
No, it does. No, no, that's
that's what you just read. You read it.
Is that the official teaching of the
sevenday adventure 1844?
Uh that is the author's the emphasis. I
see uh I I think I do believe in 1844
but that for me the concept is the most
important thing. The concept is the most
important thing. So uh that's
can we get to 1844? This is the heart of
your prophecy. This is why I came to
this.
You got to drive you got to drive the
the discourse with judgment uh with John
and these sort of other areas. So Sam
has mentioned 1844 a number of times. So
maybe you can help because again the the
belief does include 1844 and um they're
essentially saying that uh there's
biblical warrant or support for it. So
maybe you can point him to where the
belief why is the belief citing 1844.
Okay.
Uh 184. So before uh Adventists uh
understood that uh Daniel 8:14 refers to
1844 they already understood that the
judgment was passed. the year 1798 based
upon the reformational understanding of
Daniel chapter 7. Josiah Lich spoke was
the first one who came up with the
concept of the investigative judgment.
He said it needs to happen after 1798
in 1842. Why? Because he said a judgment
is being mentioned after the reign of
the little horn. Now uh
I'm having a hard time hearing you
honestly. I'm not trying to touch the
sevenour time
on this.
Okay, let me try it again. I said so
initially Adventist came up not with the
investigative judgment in 1844. It was
already understood in 1842.
Josiah Lich understood based upon Daniel
chapter 7 that after the reign of the
little horn a judgment is being
mentioned. So the the predominantly the
Yes.
Because we find that sequence. We see
that sequence.
Yeah, but I'm trying to follow. If you
go too fast, then you're not talking to
me.
Okay. Okay.
Little horn. Okay. I'm trying to figure
out. So, Daniel 7
after the little horn. What again?
After the little horn was raining for
1260. Uh it speaks about the period of
1260s. Okay. Right.
And and it's also explained in the
latter part of Daniel 7. It says and
after this the judgment. So Josiah Lit
said after 1798 there should be a
judgment
and that was based upon pro protestant
uh protest protestant understanding of
the
1798.
Yeah.
So he assigned 1798 from Daniel 7.
Yes.
that from Daniel 7
because again Protestant understanding
of prophecy was predominantly that the
little horn refers to papacy and that it
ended in 1798
708.
So Protestants said it's the papacy and
what happened to the papacy in 1798?
It was uh the general took uh uh the
pope captive. The what?
The general of of of Napoleon took the
pope captive.
Oh yeah. And that's why the pope is
still strong and the church Catholic
church is spreading. So since that was a
failed understanding, how does that
justify 1798?
It understood it was so the that u
situation was understood as the
fulfillment of the ending of the reign
of the little horn. And after that
it hasn't stopped raining. So I'm still
waiting. after that after that it speaks
about a judgment coming up. So I just
want I'm just I'm explaining I'm
explaining why we are getting to 1844.
So already
already back then we without looking to
Daniel 8 verse14
Adventist Millerites
Losiah Josiah was a scholar he
understood it. Wait a second. We have
here a trial. By the way, you already
said the trial is done by God the
Father, Christ will execute it post
Calvary and somewhere around the period
of the 18th in the 18th century. So,
what's where in Daniel? I'm still
waiting, brother. You're preaching.
Yeah. Let's go to Daniel. Where are you
pointing to in scripture for this? We're
supposed to be discussing scripture.
Can you give me the verses? Because
Daniel 7 doesn't assign at 1798. They're
appealing to some Protestants who say,
"Oh, see the Pope uh Napoleon took the
Pope captive. See, that's now the end."
Well, that's okay. So, what he said that
the proof give me exesus.
Open up Daniel 7, Daniel 8. Let's go.
Show me.
Oh, Daniel 7. You know yourself. Daniel
7 goes together with Daniel 2. those
those uh those Daniel 2,
Daniel chapter 2 with the the statue
with the different medals they agree
with Daniel chapter 7 in terms of the
four beasts and then we have Rome being
mentioned and that Rome out of that oath
of Rome came a little horn. So we have
here4
miles because this guy's preaching
because Daniel 2 doesn't help his case.
Let's go and look at let's go and look
at Daniel because here hold on fellas.
Hold on fellas. Hold on fellas. Okay.
All right. I'm gonna start stepping in a
little bit more because we want to have
a productive and fruitful conversation.
I know we get passionate. I know. Um but
there's a lot of stuff being thrown out
when we should just go to these verses.
So all of the things that Joel is saying
right now, and I think he would agree
with this, are necessary for all of this
to be true, not just 1844. So, let's go
to Daniel 7 or Daniel 2 if that's what
we want to do. And let's see where the
text is the text teaching. Is it
supporting what Joel is saying or is it
supporting something else that Sam is
going to say? Bring up my bring up my
can you bring up I don't know what
you're bringing. Okay. Daniel 2. This
not going to help your case because it
says the messianic kingdom will be
established in the reign of those
kingdoms.
Now somehow you're taking it to mean the
Roman Catholic Church when in the
context it's talking about the empires
such as Babylon, Midas Persia, Greece
and Rome. You now take Rome to mean the
Roman Catholic Church when its
historical context is talking about the
empires, the superpowers.
And so if you go to Daniel 2 34:35
because even Muslims misuse this sadly.
But all these empires they are sequently
when the when the when the destroyed
when it is destroyed when the when the
looking until a stone was cut out with
hands and it struck the image on its
feet of iron and clay and crushed them.
Then the iron, the clay, the bronze, the
silver and the gold were crushed all at
the same time when and became like chav
from the summer threshing floors and the
wind carried them away so that not a
trace of them was found. that the stone
that struck image became a great
mountain and filled the whole earth. If
I read this contextually, it's talking
about during those four empires,
during the fourth one, the other three
still will not have been completely
wiped out. And historically,
do you want to manifest again? I mean, I
can read it for you.
No, I said I said yeah, I I agree.
Okay, so it says it starts out as a
stone, but then it will end up become a
great mountain. Meaning this stone
without hands will slowly engulf the
earth. That's why it starts as a stone
and it becomes a great mountain that
eventually fills the earth. This goes
back to the point I made earlier.
When did this happen?
Okay. Well, brother, if I have to break
this down, you know, there's no
discussion because you're wasting time.
But the stone that struck the image
became a great mountain and filled the
whole earth.
Okay. So, do you want me to repeat it
again? But the stone which is not a
mountain that struck image became a
great mount. Meaning it starts as a
stone during these empires and slowly it
becomes a great mountain that eventually
fills the earth. That's exactly the
point I was making earlier when Jesus
said he's already begun the judgment,
begun the resurrection and will
culminate when he returns.
Joel, what was your what was your
question to Sam?
My question is my question was when did
this was fulfilled?
When Christ came. Okay, that's when you
say and
okay I I I I will disagree based upon
Daniel 7 where we have um think about
also this Daniel chapter 9 maybe I'm now
uh jumping to Daniel chapter 9 and
Daniel chapter 11 we see here we see
here that this entity based upon Daniel
11 verse 22 Daniel 11 verse 22 the
entity which will stood up against
Christ um um based Okay. So is the Roman
is is the Roman army is the Roman power.
Daniel 11
is not about Rome. It's about Antiochus
that preig 11:20. It speaks about the
Daniel is about Antiochus who prefigures
the antichrist. Yes. Because Daniel 11
You can say all you know you want dude.
I'm going to show it to you from Daniel
8 and 11. Take it easy.
Go ahead. Go ahead.
Yes. Because the same Daniel 11 36
to 37, that same figure is the same one
of Daniel 8, which is your proof text
that you've been running from, which
I've been waiting for you to bring up,
that little horn. It's the same figure.
And historically, that's Antiochus. And
I'm going to demonstrate that here. Then
the king will do as he pleases. Daniel
11:36-37. He will exalt and magnify
himself above every god. Will speak
astonishing things against the God of
gods. He will exce succeed until
ignation is finished. For that which is
decreed will be done. He will show no
regard for the gods of his fathers or
for the desire of women. Nor will he
show regard for any other god. For he
will magnify himself above them all.
Then we go to Daniel 8. Then it grew up
the host to the host of heaven, caused
some of the host and some of the stars
to fall to the earth. And it trampled
down them down and even magnified itself
to be equal with the commander of the
host and removed the regular sacrifice
from him. And the place of his sanctuary
was thrown down. I said, "I've been
waiting for you to go here, but for some
reason you've been hesitant. And on
account of transgression, the host will
be given over to the horn along with
regular sacrifice. It will throw truth
down to the ground and do its will and
succeed. Then I heard a holy one speak.
Another holy one said to that particular
one who was speaking, "How long will the
vision about the regular sacrifice apply
while the transgression causes
desolation so as to allow both the holy
place and those to be trampled?" And he
said to me, "For 2,300 evenings and
mornings," very significant, "Then a
holy place will be made righteous." So
this one will oppose the commander of
the host. And who is he? Daniel 8:25-26.
And through his insight, he will cause
the sea to succeed by his hand. He will
magnify himself in his heart. He will
destroy many while they are at ease. He
will stand against the prince of prince
Sadim. But he will be broken without
hands. And what appeared about the
evenings and the mornings which has been
told is true. But as for you, conceal
the vision, for it pertains to many days
in the future. So this is talking about
Antas. So I'm waiting for you to refute
me. Especially this is the proof text
that you you guys use this one here
which you have yet to go to.
So
that's where the 1844. So why aren't you
using this? Because Daniel 9 is not your
proof text.
uh you know
the
let me make it clear let me make it
clear the
before I go to this issue before I go to
this issue as I said already for me the
most important thing is the concept so
the timing
uh is not for me the first before first
first and foremost thing I think that
quite some adventists they have shown
why antio
could not be there are some good reasons
why he could not be the fulfillment of
prophecy. So this could be going back
and forth like yes or no. So for me
that's why I just wanted to stick
without going into these things which
could be decisive. I want to go to uh a
clear concept of the investigative
judgment without necessarily looking at
the time and we could also look at the
the sanctuary surface connected with it.
But um so when it so going back to now
Daniel chapter 9 and and chap chapter 8
9 and 10 I think that we still one of
the main reasons why I say yeah this
should be esqueological it needs such a
fulfillment because in Daniel chapter 8
um it speaks again about it shall be
onto many days and it speaks even about
the destroying of the of the uh the
little horn power. All those prophecies
reach unto the end. Daniel chapter 2,
Daniel chapter 9, uh, Daniel chapter 7,
Daniel chapter 8. So, I want to be fair.
Yeah. No, it doesn't. Daniel 8
matter of fact, Daniel 8 starts with the
messes and the Persians. Uh,
right. And that and that and and that
covers not only the meats and the
Persians, but even the Greeks and the
Rome. So for me already that indicates
that that indicates that 6 years or
seven years is not enough. If we have to
if we understand literally literal
friend no the little horn is talking
about Antiochus in its immediate
historical context and he did come about
later
or long after Midas Persia long after
Alexander when his empire was split into
four because of his four generals and
from their midst came Antiochus
this is why I said this is the text you
guys butcher to say 23 300 evenings and
mornings means 2,300 years. And then you
then tie it in with Daniel N. Butcher
that. So I'm waiting for the evidence,
but you don't want to give it to me. So
now if you don't want to go there,
that's one thing because he brought up
1844. I didn't I didn't tell Miles to
quote 1844.
No, no, no, no. Wait a second. Wait a
second. No, wait a second. I didn't. It
even in the title 1844 is not mentioned.
It speaks about the investigative
judgment. Speaks about investigative
judgement. 1844 from Daniel 8.
So uh again
without going I don't even need to speak
about 1844 I just when I just stay even
in the New Testament you see
esqueological judgment Christ executing
the judgment and uh we can go for
example to second Thessalonians chapter
1.
Miles I'm I'm a little confused. I don't
mean I'm not talking to you. Miles why
did you bring up 1844 brother? Why did
you distract us with him for he's not
here to defend 1844. So, why did you
quote it?
No, no, no, no, wait, wait a second.
Hold on, wait, Miles.
Why did you bring up what they believe
1844?
The man's not here to defend that. Why
did you waste our time in 1844? Because
I'm thinking 1844. So, why did you bring
it up, Miles? Can you explain to the
audience?
Well, I only brought it up because it's
in the fundamental belief as we see on
screen and then you were uh regularly
referring to that. So, I wanted to give
you some control time if that's where
you wanted to go. But there are
obviously other aspects of the belief
that we can
if you well
you can't obviously forget it if you
just want to I mean if you want to have
the belief but there are other things
there are other pillars that are
necessary as well.
Yes. Thank you for
now let's go into the when does the what
does the investigative
so there are many aspects and the
aspects I will defend right now is again
the order the fact that it's there in
the new testament okay
uh so and not necessarily the timing but
that is an esquetological post
Christrist event I
want to make let's let's do this I'm
gonna I'm gonna start I'm going to start
directing on some very specific points
that the belief talks about and we'll
start exploring those. We're not going
to focus on time since Joel doesn't want
to talk about time. Um, so let's focus
on this. Let's just work our way through
the belief.
So Joel, my first my first thing is
going to be it says at his ascension, he
was inaugurated as our great high priest
and began his intercessory ministry
which was typified in the work of the
high priest by the holy place of the
earthly sanctuary. Then they talk about
1844. So you have something going on
before 1844 from the ascension and
they're appealing to the Old Testament
priesthood work saying that that was a
typifying work.
Let's get into some of that. How does
the
explain that to Sam and how does the how
how does that get that from the
scripture
slowly and speak loud because again I
can't hear you too clear and you speak
fast slowly and loud so I want to hear
you but
okay so when we look at the sanctuary
surface we see three main things we see
the inauguration
for example Exodus chapter 40 we see in
Leviticus chapter 8 and 9 where uh the
whole sanctuary was inaugurated
Then we find the daily service during
the year and at the end of the seventh
or at the on the 10th day of the seventh
month we find the day of atonement. So
this is uh what we as Adventists believe
was fulfilled in an antiypical way and
it was also being uh prophesied. So for
example take Daniel chapter 9. It speaks
about um the anointing of the most holy.
Um and that is also a seen in uh Hebrews
chapter 9 when it speaks about when it
speaks about the as the earthly covenant
and sanctuary was inaugurated.
So we also see that with
inaugurated
brother text or you want to keep okay
you uh said anoint the most holy in
Daniel 9.
Yeah
that there's going to be six uh there's
77s decreed and there's going to be
627s and seven sevens for all of this to
consummate. And then you said anoint the
most holy. And you said that refers to
what again?
That refers to Christ who who
inaugurated the heavenly sanctuary in
all parts. But you are aware that it
says anoint the most holy and there's a
debate is that the sanctuary or the
person
indeed but I I I I take the site of the
of the sanctuary and the reason is that
because the definite article is used is
difficult to refer
article
for me it's relevant.
Okay. But you're not here preaching to
Adventists. You're here to try to
convince the non-adventists. Right. So
it's relevant to you, but it's
irrelevant because if we go with the
definite article, then when it says
Mashiach naged and there is no definite
article. So you're going to say anointed
ruler or is that the Messiah?
It so when it speaks to the most holy,
it's not referring to the Messiah.
You didn't hear answer my question.
That's not what I asked.
Oh, sorry. What did you say?
Let me repeat your argument. See, this
is the problem. When someone thinks he
has knowledge of the languages, this is
where it becomes dangerous. Article lack
thereof. The most holy doesn't mean it
has to be the most holy place. It must
it can refer to the one who is the holy
of all the holy ones. But okay, good.
But now I want you to apply your
argument consistently grammatically
because you're aware when you go to
Daniel 9:25, it says Mashiach Nagid will
come and then it says Messiah will be
cut off and not for himself. But there
is no article before Mashiah Naged. So
should we then translate it an anointed
ruler or is it the Messiah messianic
ruler? Would you still consider to be
definite?
That's a good question. I've not delved
into that aspect.
I've not delved into at that aspect.
That's a good point. I will I will take
notice of it.
Okay.
Uh so taking at face value. So even if
that was okay, let's say we just miss
skip that verse. Still we see we see we
do see a correspondence between the old
sanctuary cultic service where you see
an inauguration before the daily service
and again you see that also in Hebrews
chapter 9 and 10 there where where inkyo
is used in Hebrews 10 verse 20 for the
for the uh inauguration of the new uh
san he heavenly sanctuary
what's used again Hebrews 10 with all
Eno.
What is that used for?
That it means that is the word
inauguration and that is only
Hebrews 10.
Hebrews 10 verse 20.
Use what is it inaugurating? Hold on. I
know I know but I just want to say
because a lot of assumptions. Okay. Now
bring up my screen. Uh
so
you know that Hebrews chapter 10 verse
brother right here.
Yeah. Therefore, brothers, since we have
Therefore, brothers, since we have
confidence, enter other places by the
blood of Jesus by a new living way which
he inaugurated for us. What he
inaugurated was the new way to enter
into God's presence, right?
Yeah. But wait, it is connected to the
sanctuary, the hagya.
That's not the argument. The argument
here is
it it is so it is connected to the
hagya. And in the light of Hebrews
chapter 9 verse 18 to2 see again.
Yes you see again you see again the
sanctuary mentioned and not only and not
only can I 10:20 before you run to
rebite because it's what you do you take
verses and read into them what is being
inaugurated
right here by a new living way. That's
what he inaugurated. Read it.
It's there. You keep gish galloping and
running to 10,000 verses. Slow your
horses, young man. Let's do exa Jesus.
Yeah, but wait a second. He says here,
he says here that again you have to look
at the word n and which refers back to
what was formally stated which speaks
about the way
that speaks about the way of the holiest
and
repeat my argument because I don't think
you got my argument again. No one denies
this is connected with Christ making a
way for us to enter the most holy place.
You're attacking straw man.
Is is how we enter the most holy place.
It's not done by priest on earth once a
year when he can only enter and have to
leave at his own peril. It is now done
by the flesh of Christ broken for us to
give us unbroken access to the most holy
place.
I think it's part of it. But again in
the context in the context of chapter 9
because the nine chapter 9 and 10 are
close. We see
sure let's go to Hebrews chapter 9. You
will see it again.
Okay. Which verse you want me to look
at?
Chapter 9 verse 18-21.
Say it again.
8. Chapter 9 verse uh 18- 21.
All right. Do you mind if I read from
14?
Uh sure you can do that.
Because for how much more will the blood
of Christ who through the eternal spirit
offered himself without blemish to God
cleanse your conscience from dead works
to serve the living God? And for this
reason he's the mediator of a new
covenant. So that since a death has
taken place for the redemption of the
trespasses that were committed under the
first covenant, those who have been
called may receive the promise of the
eternal inheritance. For where a
covenant is, there must be of necessity
be the death of the one who made it. For
a covenant is valid only when men are
dead. For it is never enforced while the
one who made it lives. Therefore, not
even the first covenant was inaugurated
without blood. So what was inaugurated?
the covenant.
Okay. For what every commandment had
been spoken by Moses to all the people
according to the law, he took the blood
of the calves and the goats with water
and scarlet wool and hiss up and
sprinkled both the book itself and all
the people saying, "This is the blood of
the covenant which God commanded you."
In the same way, both the tabernacle and
the
No, I'm not finished. Take it easy.
Because are you getting that excited?
Thank you. No, I'm going to say thank
you because you're making my just hold
on. And in the same way, both the
tabernacle and all the vessels of the
ministry, he sprinkled with the blood.
And according law, one may almost say
all things are cleansed with blood.
Without shedding of blood, there is no
forgiveness. Now, before I read the
rest, I want to see if you know how to
connect verses and exed. So, one more
time, we're going to read this. We're
not going to go anywhere. I promise.
We're going to go all the way to 28.
For this reason, he's a meteor of a new
covenant. So that since a death has
taken place for the redemption of the
trespasses that were committed under
first covenant, those who have been
called may receive the promise of the
eternal inheritance. For a covenant is
there must of necessity be the death of
the one who made it. For a covenant is
valid only when men are dead. For it is
never in force while the one who made it
lives. Now we're going to see what
inauguration means. Therefore, not even
the first covenant was inaugurated
without blood. Do you understand the
therefore what it's meaning here? What's
the point here before we move on?
The covenant is always inaugurated with
blood.
Okay. So you now you and I agree to can
because I know Jesus cleansed is the
heavenly
that's in Hebrews 9:23. What I want you
to do is exedute properly. The
inauguration here is the covenants which
must take place by death. Right? You're
missing something out because also in
verse 21, also verse 21, it infolds the
sanctuary.
No, I'm getting there. That's stuck for
you know, you know, it here. Take it.
I'm going to get there. I just read it.
The therefore here is talking about
to me. It's clear to me. It's clear to
me.
So, it is right
now. Let's follow the train of thought.
For when every commandment had been
spoken by most all the people according
law, he took the blood of the calves and
the goats with water and scarlet wool
and hissup and sprinkled both the book
itself and all the people. Now we're
going to say what in the same way means
saying this is the blood of the covenant
which God made commanded you. And in the
same way now it's talking about the tam
being cleansed by blood. You are making
an issue of inaugurating.
What's being inaugurated is the
covenant. What's being cleansed by blood
is heavenly tabernacle. I want you to
make a distinction.
You keep nodding your head, but let's
read it one more time. Okay.
It's the same way. What? Same way here.
Let's read it again.
For when every commandment had been
spoken by Moses to all the people
according to the law.
He took the blood of the calves and the
goats with water and scar scarlet wool
and his sprinkled the book itself and
all the people saying, "This is the
blood of the covenant which God
commanded you." So, how did he
inaugurate the covenant? By blood,
right? Yeah.
And in the same way he then cleansed the
tabernacle with blood. That's all I want
you to see that the inauguration is the
covenant. And yes, the cleansing,
but you put words. You put words. It
says sprinkled. It doesn't say. So here
the act of sprinkling is part of the
inauguration process.
And you put computer to be cleansing.
No, let me read one more time. No, now
you putting it. You're pointing
something.
Not even I didn't even get to Hebrews 2
9:23. The point is two, but you can't
read it because you're reading your
theology into it. He's making two
points. The new covenant has been
inaugurated by death like the old
covenant was. Cuz when there's shedding
of blood, a death occurs also. Just like
Moses cleansed the earthly one, Christ
cleanses the heavenly one. It's making
two points, not one.
But that was al I did not deny that. I
that is why I said
that I said that is why I said it
infalls
some I said I I said the inauguration of
the new covenant going back to Hebrews
chapter 9 Hebrews chapter 9 builds upon
Hebrews chapter 8 chapter 8 speaks about
a new covenant now okay
wait this here
chapter 8
just give me 10 seconds
chapter 8 speaks about the new covenants
B chapter 9 verse one said as the old
covenant had a sanctuary so Paul is also
showing in Hebrews chapter 9 that the
new covenant has a sanctuary so
I'm talking about inauguration which you
misapplied that's all I'm correcting now
I
I'm just saying that involves also the
okay buddy can get inauguration of the
heavenly sanctuary when
we get to the cleansing here's your
cleansing therefore it was necessary for
the copies of the things in the heavens
to be cleansed with these with the
heavenly things themselves with better.
Now, here's the cleansing. Okay. Now,
tie this in with the investigative
judgment. Now, finally, we get to I want
to see how you're going to connect us
with the investigative judgment.
This let Joel really quick, really
quick. Let's let Joel talk here
uninterrupted for a few minutes and just
make sure he gets everything out here.
That way, we can really engage with the
point.
Okay. This text does not necessarily uh
need to be tied in with the
investigative judgment. It could be if I
have to take that route. We should
remind oursel that here the uh
infinitive is used. The infinitive
does not denote temporal time. So this
could be applied to any time. So this
text does not really give me any
evidence because it could be in the past
but it also will be in the future. Why I
say in the future? Because some will say
verse 24 and 25 speak about the day of
atonement. So if you connect it with
that it could be the day of atonement
but uh uh it could also be but again
verse 23 already shows that it is not
necessarily happening at the cross when
the Christ event because the verb tense
of the infinitive does not maintain time
reference in such a way. So that will be
this text I don't really this text is
for me not a strong one in either way.
I can't keep up with him because he
speak 50,000 miles per hour. Slow it
down buddy. That's why I'm cutting off.
Okay. I said this text.
Yeah, I know what you said about the
infinitive since you say conclusive.
It's not familiar. Strong evidence in
either way.
Can we get to your strong evidence?
Because I was about to show you
contextually does improve your But
what's your strongest evidence?
The the strong for what specific point?
What was this? Which specific
investigative judgment?
Yes. So going back to my main thesis
what I wanted to what I said is that in
in the New Testament you will see the
sequence uh inauguration and I mentioned
Hebrews chapter 9 verse 18-21 and then
we find a then we find uh the we find an
atonement post Calvary. We find that in
two verses. My favorite.
Okay. Real quick, just to make sure
people got he said he said, "Then we
find an atonement post Calvary."
Continue.
Hebrews 2:17. Very clear. Very clear.
That's
No, mute to you. It's clear. Hold on.
Let me bring it up. Tech and look at
Let's go to the Greek. Please go to the
Oh, here we go again. Here.
Okay. You don't Let's establish the
Let's establish what the point is here.
So, so Joel, what's the point of going
here to say that the that this text is
teaching that there is an atonement post
Calvary?
Okay. So, here it speaks about very
clearly. It speaks about let me just get
the Greek.
That's Hebrews 217. I know.
Yeah. So, Hebrews 2:17
is already I mean, we all know that
Christ already died on the cross. Then
it mentions Christ as a high priest. And
then it says there uh let me get there
on the screen.
It says
that that word that is an infinitive
speak louder. We know what means. Yes.
Propitiation. Okay.
No hilarion is the noun. We are not
speaking about the noun.
I'm giving you hilmas. I know the family
of words. I didn't tell you what exact
word.
Okay. Not to correct me because your
Greek is no good. But keep going. Go
ahead. Yeah.
Yeah. No, go ahead. Go. Easy. Yes. Go
ahead. What's the point here?
So, the the infinitive is used in the
present tense. We are dealing here with
an atonement. This word is the most
important word for atonement. We have
also in the Greek, but here he's using
me. Well, the one thing I'm going to ask
you, stop appealing Greek because you're
going to get butchered in the Greek.
Stop insulting me. Just get to the point
cuz I'm going to use this and I'll show
you. You don't know Greek existence.
Just get to the point.
I already told you it's an infinitive in
the present tense.
Okay. So,
but Joel, what does that prove? How does
that prove the investigative judgment?
Yes, we are dealing here. I I'm saying
no, I'm saying here it speaks about an
atonement. Hey, don't don't forget guys
what I just mentioned. I said it speaks
about an atonement.
How does he make atonement in
post Calvary in heaven?
How does he make it atonement in heaven?
applying his blood.
Say it again.
I would say applying his blood.
Priestly,
there is nobody. There's nobody
presenting his blood.
Can I make my point? There's nobody that
denies that part of Christ's priestly
ministry min ministry is to present the
sacrifice of Calvary to the father as
the basis by which he keeps interceding.
But that's not something he does in 1844
or wherever. I don't know what date you
want to sign it. He's been doing to
heaven. So, we're still trying to see
how your knowledge of Greek is making
your case. What's the evidence?
It is an atonement. It is an atonement.
What's that atonement again? Repeat it.
It's the word.
What is the atonement that he's making?
He's being slain in the most holy place.
No, that is the presentation of the
blood. The presenting of the blood. Just
as we have seen in the daily service,
the sacrifice was killed and then the
high priest had to present the blood.
What is Christ's offering in the most
holy place?
I wait a second. I did not say the most
holy place because Paul is what does
No, I'm going to bury you in Hebrews 9,
which you loved. Hold on. I'm going to
show you.
He when Paul said listen to the dude,
are you scared of the Bible? I don't do
no scared.
Please, please.
Let's go. Let's go.
Okay. Let's let's let's
focus things up here. So, you're still
continuing, Joel, to prove the point
correct that there is a postcalvary
atonement, right? And you're saying that
it is
and you're not saying that it is a
slaying work, but that it is a
presentation work. Correct.
Yes. To present to Indeed. Indeed.
Now, do you know of anyone do you as a
Presbyterian deny that? Um, well, it
just depends how we're essentially
defining words. I need to I need to stay
I need to stay neutral. Obviously, we
but obviously we don't but of course we
of course know we do not deny that Jesus
presented his sacrifice. So, you need to
get a little bit more specific Joel
about the investigative judgment aspect
but close again as I said the word
itself is a word which denotes
atonement. So, we're talking here about
atonement. How is he making atonement?
It's presenting the sacrifice of
Calvary, not that he's being sacrificed
in the most holy place. And you agree
with that, I think.
I didn't say that.
So now, so, so now,
let me read Hebrews 9 when he started.
Can I read Hebrews 9?
Yeah, go ahead.
Hold on. Let me read to the script. He
Hebrews 9:22 to 28. And according to the
law, one may almost say, all things are
cleansed with blood. Without shedding of
blood, there is no forgiveness.
Therefore, it was necessary for the
copies of the things in the heavens to
be cleansed with these, but the heavenly
things themselves with better sacrifices
than these. For Christ did not enter
holy places made with hands, mere copies
and ruins, but into heaven itself now to
appear in the presence of God for us.
Nor was it that he would offer himself
often as high priest enters the holy
places year by year without blood that
is not his own. Otherwise, he would have
to needed to suffer often since the
foundation world. But now once at the
consummation of the ages he has been
made manifested to put away the sin by
the sacrifice of himself. In as much as
it is appointed to for men to die once
and after this comes judgment. So Christ
also having been offered once to bear
the sins of many will appear second time
for salvation without reference to sin
to those who eagerly await him. So
according to the context, why did he
enter into God's heavenly presence to do
what again?
Uh the the context here speaks about the
singularity of Christ dying that he died
once.
It's to die. It says here to offer for
the uh for the uh many sins
pro.
So what is I know what means stop trying
to press me with the Greek you don't
know it's contrasting with the high
priest on earth. So when they enter the
most holy place what were they doing
presenting?
He is not he is verse 24 is not speaking
about the most holy places speak about
the whole
Christ did not enter holy places made
with hands mere cop but into heaven
itself now watch how it's going to bury
you just be patient now the presence of
god for us the presence of god for nor
was it that he would offer himself off
and as the high priest
yeah but wait a second the highest
year let me finish it year by year this
is the day of atonement
no you know why it's not the year by
year. It didn't say day by day.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no. It speaks
first of all, it cannot be by year.
Yeah. Listen, listen, listen, listen,
listen. You have this text, this phrase
year
out is is is explained in Hebrews
chapter 10 verse 1-4.
Listen, listen. There it speaks.
This guy wasting our time. He's he's a
joke, man. I'm serious. I'm serious.
Oh my goodness.
Here, let him let him let him finish his
point. Let him finish. If you want to
have a discussion, you can have it
because this guy's a waste because the
context is clear.
Jesus enters the presence of God
place.
He doesn't say hagon. He speaks about
the whole sanctuary.
He doesn't need to. He says the presence
of God and contrast that with the high
priest who does it on earth. Only
someone who's committed to a false
prophetist would have to butcher.
But the presence of God sanctuary
it applies to the whole sanctuary. Wait.
No. Not here when it says ear by ear.
No. No. If Paul Listen, go to verse
seven. Go to verse seven.
Take Hebrews 9:7. Go
Hebrews 8. Take it easy. Hebrews 8. Your
burial because you went to Hebrews 8.
Now the main point in what is being said
is this. We have such high priests who
sat down at the right hand of the throne
of the majesty of heavens. Where is the
throne of the majesty in heavens?
Where is the throne in the majesty of
heavens? Stop the game. I'm getting
tired.
In the sanctuary, but you know that
there are
Where is Jesus now?
Listen, there are many furnitureures in
the sanctuary. You explain me, right? I
see.
No, explain this. The throne of the
majesty is where?
It's it's in the heavenly sanctuary.
Which part?
Both parts. It could be both parts
because of both.
You know why?
You know why? Because those those
furnitureures they had crowns. They had
crowns. Take for example the the the the
the
altar of incense which was in the holy
place. It had crowns.
Was there God's throne there or behind
the veil in the most holy place?
Both sides.
God's throne was the veil,
but God also was communicating. Oh,
that's not what I asked. Mercy seat, the
ark of the covenant. Where was it?
That was in the most holy place.
Okay, because I was going to go to
Hebrews 9 to bear you again. You think
you know Greek. So now let's everyone
heard you. So the mercy seat, the throne
of God, the majesty, where is it?
Wait, wait, but now you're making it.
Wait, now you're making an assumption
that you want him to give us five
minutes closing statement because I
think we're wasting time now.
We don't have to make that assumption.
You are connecting the throne of God
always with the most with the uh with
the mercy not that it's not
the ark of the covenant, the mercy seat
and the earthly tabernacle was located
where
where do we see it in Hebrews chapter
chapter 8 and 9:es 1 to8. Now even the
first covenant had requirements of
divine worship and earthly sanctuary.
For there was a tabernacle prepared, the
first part in which were the lampstand
and the table and the sacred bread which
is called the holy place. Behind the
second veil, there was a tabernacle
which is called the holy of holies,
having a golden altar of incense, the
ark of the covenant covered on all sides
with gold, and which was a golden jar
holding the mana and Aaron's rod which
the tablets of the covenant and above it
with a cherubim overshadowing the mercy
seat. I'm going to ask you again so see
if you're going to play games.
Yeah, but it doesn't say it's not a
throne. It doesn't say that only that is
the throne. That's
you want to give us five minutes closing
statements, brother? Because we're
wasting time.
He said well well he said his point was
that that's not the only throne. So he's
saying that there's other things that
was a throne in the holy place, God's
throne in the holy place. Was there a
throne?
Okay. So we know it's symbolic, right?
So as as I said,
those furnitureures which had crowns
symbolize also God's one make easy for
you Joel. I'm not asking about symbolic.
There was an actual mercy seat, arc of
the covenant design behind the most
holy.
Sure. Sure.
Was there an ark of the mercy seat in
the holy place and in the most holy
place?
Yes, indeed. Sure. Wait, would you say
it again? Uh, was there? Yeah, both.
Was there a mercy seat ark of the
covenant in the holy place as well as
behind the most holy place?
We all know it was only in the most holy
place.
Oh, good. Now, can we
No, no, no.
Can we already said you don't have to
make the connection where is Jesus
making?
Where is Jesus sitting?
At the right hand of God, not at the
right.
No, no, no, no, no. Read it again. Where
is Jesus sitting?
At the right hand of the throne of God.
Where is God's throne in heaven?
Again, you only apply it to the mercy
seat. I would not I would not conclude
that. Hey brother, I think it's we can
wrap it up, man. Let him get his five
minutes closing statement.
Hey, hey, hey. Okay. Hey, you know what?
Again, when Paul think about this when
Paul speaks about
I'm done, brother. So, I don't know if
you want to keep preaching. I'm telling
you, this is wasting my time and yours.
Let him make his five-minute closing.
When I when I talk, it's called
preaching. When When you talk, it's not
calling preaching anymore because I want
to go. I want to go.
I'm getting moderator instead of being
silent. Moderator, you give us five
minutes so we can wrap it up. Sam, Sam,
Sam, I really I'm disappointed because
you know
I want to lose sleep over you.
Okay.
Yeah.
Give us five minutes, man. We're done
here.
Okay, Miles, maybe. Okay, let me give my
five minutes. Right. So, when Paul
really speaks about the day of atonement
in uh verse Hebrews 9:7, he calls he
talks about any outon as well, but he
says hak to any outon hap once in a
year. when he speaks about the whole
cultic uh uh uh surface he says anyon
again Hebrews 9:24
24 kaon verse 7 hak and you when you go
to Hebrews chapter 10 verse 1-4 again
you see the whole cultic uh is in few
and only kata and aon is used so I that
is the point I wanted to make
you're done now
because now I'm going to bury your hap
and your faint knowledge of and then
that's it. So we're done. So again guys,
this is an illustration of someone who
doesn't know Greek, pretends he knows
Greek and butchers the Greek because
it is not simp.
Why are you cutting me off?
I didn't cut you off. These are closing
statements. Take it easy. I know you're
embarrassed cuz your religion got time
for you to repent. Can I make my case?
Okay, brethren. This is where an
illustration of a little Greek can be
dangerous because he doesn't know Greek.
He thinks he does because notice
when concepts are used to teach the same
point
that Jesus enters the presence of God in
the context that's contrasted with the
high priest who enters yearbyear. And
where does he enter? not day by day
daily the most holy place showing that
Christ enters the most holy place that's
where God's presence is and this is
confirmed by the fact that Christ is
seated at the right hand of the majesty
on high which is to be seated at the
right hand of the throne of the majesty
of the heavens which if you heard him
with all his rambling and distortion of
the Greek he goes yeah yeah yeah but the
ark of the covenant it's only in the
most holy place but symbol ically you
can say God's throne is in all of it but
we know there's only one mercy seat an
ark of covenant and most holy place and
yet Jesus is sitting at the right hand
of the throne of the majesty if the
earthly is a replica of the heavenly
then that means the ark of the covenant
mercy seat that is supposed to be a
replica of the throne in the most holy
place where is Jesus he's in the most
holy place where is he seated in the
most holy place That's where he went.
That's where he's interceding and
presenting his blood. All of his
arguments is based on taking a snippet
here, a snippet there, butchering this,
butchering that, feigning Greek, and
when the Greek backfires against him,
running and doing dish galloping. This
is proof. This is a cult. And LG White
is a tool of Satan. I pray he repents.
So Lord bless you.
I I did not even mention Ella White, my
brother. I don't know why you mentioned
this. Um, have you also
Funny, we're done. I don't know why
you're trying to preach. It was closing
statements. So, what do you appreciate?
Okay.
All right, folks. Thank you for being
here. I know this was a bit of a
dumpster fire. Gentlemen, I appreciate
both of you being here. Um, I understand
sometimes we get heated in discussions.
It's also a little hard with technology.
Sometimes I think there's a little bit
of a lag as well as not the best
microphones, but hopefully the Lord will
use this for his purposes however he
sees fit. As always folks, thank you for
being here and may Christ richly bless
you in the grace and peace by him and
his vicarious death on the cross for
sinners. Hallelujah.
[Music]